il est 21h30 lorsqu'une personne à moto
se stationnent dans cette rue
perpendiculaire de l'avenue jean jaurès
son complice à pied lui s'approche d'un
groupe massés devant ce panneau
publicitaire et ouvre le feu avec une
arme automatique
selon nos confrères de l'est républicain
un homme de 45 ans a été blessée aux
jambes
il s'est réfugié dans cet arrêt de bus
situé à quelques mètres de là dans la
rue beaucoup de témoins assistent à la
scène comme ce gérant de ce bar les gens
aux bars sont complètement se sont
affolés bien que ça se passait de
l'autre côté c'est quand même assez
impressionnant et les gens se sont mis
derrière le comptoir tout le monde peut
chez au sol et grosse panique il y avait
un couple la dame qui pleurait on a
essayé de la calmer elle est éprise de
crise qu'on a essayé de calmer puis nous
on a fermé les portes du bar et en
attendant que la police arrive très vite
les secours font appeler les forces de
l'ordre arrivent sur place la police
technique et scientifique gel la scène
de crime et récupère des douilles de 9
mm une enquête a été ouverte afin de
comprendre ce qui s'est réellement passé
mais selon les premiers éléments il
pourrait s'agir d'un règlement de
comptes